bien nous allons à présent puisque vous
êtes vous particulièrement très gentil
vous interprétez un petit sketch que
personnellement j'aime beaucoup parce
moi pas du tout est ok marc bidou pas
suivi ne l'a jamais compris pourquoi
vous permettez je vous en prie merci
je vais tonnes enfin comment comment il
est pas neuf heures à nos îles et 20h50
excusez moi je suis un peu en avance
c'est rien ça arrive à tout le monde
et ben voilà il est juste 9
j'aurais pas voulu vous faire rater leur
oui moi quand j'ai pas l'heure j'ai la
tête à l'envers
ce qui prouve bien qu'on aurait tort de
se faire du souci en tout cas vous les
administrés très bien c'est bien si vous
être gentil est ce que vous faites dans
la vie aux administrateurs en tout cas
vous les gens qui s'y est très bien
c'est vous faites vous dans l'arène
trouve à venir talbot logis je vous ai
vu la wii alors là je ne vois pas vous
voyez pas non je ne vois pas vous ne
voyez ne me vois pas du tout si vous
préférez par exemple eu aucune is now
qu'ulysse oui je vois vous mais je vois
je vois très bien ce sera deux mille
francs ben c'est pas cher au réalisateur
va pas se quitter comme ça ce sera
dommage j'aime pas tellement